Canadian Prime Minister and
international leftist darling Justin
Trudeau has been caught wearing
blackface in several photos from the 90s
and early 2000s right left and center
black white and brown no one is actually
offended by the photos the problem is
the hypocrisy we will examine the
surprising history of blackface and how
all of us should react then NBC launches
a climate change confessional for the
left's environmental religion of course
Protestant environmentalists are furious
about this preferring instead to confess
to the earth directly we will examine
the new secular sacrament finally the
mailbag all that and more on Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love this story so much I want you to
shoot it straight into my veins
I can't wait for even more pictures of
Justin Trudeau and blackface to come out
this is the funniest story in weeks and
yet no one's actually offended by it
we're all just pretending so we will get
into how to respond because on the one
hand conservatives say nobody really
cares obviously nobody's actually upset
about it so maybe we should let it go on
the other hand we say the left uses
blackface as a cudgel they would never
let this go if this were a conservative
and yet the left gets to play by their
own rules so we need to smack them over
the head for it we'll get to the real
answer to that question but first I've
got to thank our friends over at Optima
tax relief if you owe the government
back taxes brace yourself because today
may be the day that the IRS shows up at
your home or work you're not gonna know
when they're gonna show up they're not
gonna give you a warning they're not
going to tell you so you've always got
this constant level of stress you're
right to be afraid the IRS has the power
to take everything from you your bank
accounts your paycheck even your home
and business but you can get yourself
out of this situation and look it's easy
to fall into tax problems the tax code
is very complicated people men in
particular tend to be a little lazy
about these things maybe you forgot to
report this maybe you didn't do that
maybe you just didn't file your taxes I
don't know here's what you need to do
you you can fix this but you've got to
act now call Optima tax relief there is
a reason that Optima has resolved over a
billion dollars of tax debt for people
like you
Optima takes over everything that's
going on they fight for you they end
your IRS nightmare they stop the demand
letters they stop aggressive collection
actions and they stop the IRS from
targeting you don't go into this alone
Optima is really good they know this
landscape so well that's why they've
resolved a billion dollars in tax
problems if you go in this alone the IRS
is gonna crush you I'm sorry to tell you
that but that's just the way it works
we're talking about the federal
government here largest bureaucracy
largest government in history call
Optima ask about the Fresh Start
initiative
IRS program that could save you
thousands if you qualify nobody knows
more about this powerful IRS program
than Optima call Optima for your free
consultation now while you still have
options you might not have options
forever tomorrow you might not have them
so call one eight hundred sixty-five
eight eight zero four four one eight
hundred six five eight eight zero four
four that is 1-866 in two Mattacks
relief calm these photos come out these
photos come out of justin trudeau
i was on an airplane when these came out
and obviously you know i had to get the
Wi-Fi I had to get on Twitter it was so
hilarious because the photos come out
first of him dressed up in what the left
was calling brown face wearing an
Arabian costume you know the left the
left is so dishonest on black face
when leftists wear black face they
excuse and ignore it when conservatives
even so much as talk a brat black face
they take their careers away from them
they that they wouldn't even say the
Trudeau was wearing blackface they
called it brown face because they wanted
to draw a distinction between blackface
and some other category brown face even
though they're exactly the same thing so
they came up ex post facto with this
logic they came up with this logic and
said well because Trudeau was only
appearing as an Arab person that isn't
blackface that's brown face really what
the difference is is that brown face is
black face worn by leftists that's the
only actual difference why is that
because by their logic they say no no
Arabs are brown and black people are
black so that's why there are separate
words just a little correction here
black people aren't black they're brown
they're not like actual just like the
color black they're different shades of
brown it's all the same it's all the
same thing but they want to have a
distinction without a difference because
they don't want to admit then a major
leftist darling politician wore
blackface The Daily Beast right now that
left-wing outlet The Daily Beast is
referring to this as face darkening they
couldn't even go into the brown face
thing they couldn't go into the brown
face thing because
the brownface logic fell apart when it
turned out later that justin trudeau had
worn blackface as well meaning he was
specifically dressing up as black people
one of whom was Harry Belafonte is a
very famous Jamaican American musician
it's just so disingenuous for comparison
just a reminder when megyn kelly who you
know megyn kelly was on a right-leaning
news channel fox news she then went over
to a left-leaning news channel the
audience never forgave her for working
with conservatives so she was on a show
on NBC and she just discussed the
question of blackface and wearing makeup
that makes your skin look darker she
just disgust him they took her entire
show they tried to take her entire
career away from her here are the
comments you do get in trouble if you
are a white person who puts on Halloween
or a black person who puts on white face
for Halloween like back when I was a kid
that was okay as long as you were
dressing up it's like that's character
there was a controversy on the Real
Housewives of New York with LuAnn as she
dresses Diana Ross and she made her skin
look darker than it really is and people
said that that was racist and I don't
know I felt like who doesn't love Diana
Ross she wants to look like Diana Ross
for one day I don't know how like that
got races on hollow white that comment
which is pretty much as innocuous as it
gets
got Megyn Kelly's career taken away from
her just for comparison here is Jimmy
Kimmel's blackface performance not
comments about life is full-on blackface
black body performance that he did a few
years before before he got picked to
host one of the largest late-night
comedy shows on network television in
the country sometime at night call below
look up in sky and say what the hell
going on up there
you fo live on another planet phone and
hold like et calm alone read on TV about
white people getting deducted by alien
sticking all kind of hell up day but and
that's a damn thing now home alone never
see no Flying Saucer his self but if he
do that's gonna be a spooky time that's
why it's home alone say government got
to step up and give 102 percent to
keeping them little green man off this
here earth because the day them dude
stick something up calm alone but that's
go well daddy ain't gonna be no good
time for nobody
especially call below but by the way the
whole joke the whole joke he's doing
beyond just coloring his skin brown the
joke is that Karl Malone is an idiot and
doesn't speak the English language well
what jimmy kimmel is doing is much much
closer to a minstrel show which is the
origin of blackface then any of the
other examples but there are a lot of
other examples because it isn't just
Jimmy Kimmel it's Jimmy Fallon it's Ted
Danson it's Joni Mitchell you know Joni
Mitchell they paved paradise put up she
wore blackface
Billy Crystal host of the Oscars Cyndi
Lauper Sarah Silverman Fred Armisen from
Saturday Night Live all of them were
blackface all of them in all of those
cases worked out just fine they didn't
lose their careers nor should they have
I don't think Jimmy Kimmel even should
lose his career for doing this sketch I
don't think any of the other ones should
lose their careers for doing their
blackface sketches some people have
brought up the governor of Virginia who
in a yearbook photo from his medical
school yearbook was accused of having
worn blackface because there was this
photo of him a photo of a man in
blackface on his page now he hasn't
admitted that it was him he could have
been the other guy in the photo who was
wearing a Ku Klux Klan uniform that guy
Ralph Northam still the governor of
Virginia oh by the way Northam Northam
so he may warn blackface okay he may
have worn a Ku Klux Klan outfit that's
worse
that's definitely worse he also said on
radio that we should kill babies after
they've been born that that's probably
were
than either of the first two if I view
if you were just asking me sitting
governor what's worse he wore blackface
30 years ago
or he wore a Ku Klux Klan costume 30
years ago obviously not to a Klan rally
but just as a costume or he says that
right now well he has political power
while he is making and enforcing laws in
Virginia that we should be able to kill
babies after they've been born I'm gonna
go out on a limb here and say that last
one is worse I've said this comment
before I've made this apparently
controversial remark before when I said
that last time I said that Media Matters
tried to get me fired for saying that
I'm pretty sure it's worse to kill
babies after they've been born than to
wear blackface which means according to
Media Matters it's better to kill babies
after they've been born than to wear
blackface I guess Media Matters wants us
to change the laws in this country make
it legal to kill babies after they've
been born but make it illegal to wear
blackface we're gonna have to change to
all the punishments and of course no one
really believes that no one nobody
really believes that obviously it is the
case that there are some instances of
wearing blackface that are not offensive
to people how do we know that because
all those other people wore blackface
and all those other people still have
their careers and all those other people
haven't been boycotted and all those
other people are still perfectly popular
you know the last time a blackface story
was breaking I think it actually was the
Ralph Northam story I had just gotten
into an uber with a black driver the
story had just broke and I asked what he
thought about it maybe was on the radio
or maybe it had just been all over the
news that day and he brought up the
difference he actually brought up the
point that I just made which is the
difference between wearing blackface and
wearing the Ku Klux Klan hood and he
said blackface if it's all in good fun
doesn't bother him at all the Ku Klux
Klan hood it's hard to wear that in good
fun so we didn't agree with that
he said that's different of course
that's different so the question is how
should we react to the photos of Trudeau
certainly as conservatives maybe even
centrists
regular old liberals nobody cares about
the photos themselves everybody cares
about the hypocrisy it's the same thing
Matt Walsh tweeted this out today it's
the same reason that the left goes after
a Republican senator like Larry Craig
for trying to pick up men for sex in an
airport bathroom it's not because the
left disagrees with having sex with men
in Airport bathrooms they'll do all
sorts of weird stuff it's because of the
hypocrisy Larry Craig the alleged
hypocrisy at least Larry Craig says that
he opposes redefining marriage for
instance to include gay unions and yet
he engages in in homosexual acts himself
and this is apparently hypocrisy and so
that's the same thing here the left
talks a big game on blackface but they
don't actually care unless it's
politically useful to them so what what
we like in this case is to see the
Liberals hoisted on their own petard but
I think there is a third way here I
actually think there's there's a way
between just totally letting Trudeau off
the hook and between trying to get him
to resign I think there is a third way
and what it has to do is the meaning of
blackface itself and the history of
blackface itself which nobody knows
because no one cares about history or
nuance or context anymore we'll get to
that in one second but first I have got
to thank our friends over at rank rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you probably already know about there's
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone that's thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices I
love ring I was just on the road I was
in New York for most of the last week
what I love about ring is you can have
access to your home from anywhere so if
you've got some guy coming up delivering
a package you can see him you can talk
to him
that video will get uploaded to the
cloud so if someone comes over and
they're try to rob you you got that too
you can scare them away to my senior
producer Jonathan hey he came over or he
was rather at his own house middle of
the night some weird
drug-addled maniacs tried to come in and
get into his house he spoke to them from
his own bed in his bedroom then they
chased him away I gave a ring out as a
housewarming gift to another couple of
couple friend of mine and they
immediately installed it and they were
wondering who this creeper was that was
making noise all around their house and
I turned out it was a possum and now
they kind of liked the possum they know
it gives you peace of mind as a listener
right now you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit with a video doorbell
and motion-activated floodlight camera
the starter kit has everything you need
to build a ring of security around your
own home
get started today ring.com slash Knowles
that is ring comm slash Knowles why is
nobody actually offended by the Justin
Trudeau black face by the black face
itself why is no-one actually offended
it's because no one believes that Justin
Trudeau hates black people nobody
believes it I don't like Justin Trudeau
but I get a kick out of him actually I
sort of think if he didn't exist
conservatives would have had to build
him in a lab somewhere because he's such
a caricature of a leftist politician but
no one thinks he hates black people
nobody thinks Joni Mitchell hates black
people nobody believes any of that when
Billy Crystal put on blackface to do an
impression of Sammy Davis jr. he
darkened his skin he couldn't have done
the impression otherwise Billy Crystal
doesn't look like Sammy Davis jr. when
you do impressions and impersonations of
people you've got to make yourself look
and appear like them that's what an
impression is that's what an
impersonation is same thing with Fred
Armisen Fred Armisen isn't black but
he'd be darkened his skin to look like
Barack Obama he put on blackface to use
the term but he couldn't have done the
impression otherwise you can't go and be
a white guy and do an impression of
Obama then just don't do the impression
because you're not gonna look like the
person so so are we then saying that
white people can't imitate anyone else
we came to impressions we can't do
impersonations unless they have exactly
the same skin tone that you do how about
when the Wayans brothers whitened their
faces to play white chicks remember that
movie white chicks
I actually don't I mean this was like 20
years ago or something that it came out
but they look like they
white in their faces and they play white
chicks is that okay there are they not
allowed to do that
how about when the Jersey Shore came out
Jersey Shore TV show all of a sudden you
saw it so parties start cropping up I
went to a number of them where people
were wearing you know the white tank top
and gold chains and things that I
actually just wear under my clothing
every single day of my life but they did
it to kind of look like Italian people
sometimes maybe they dork and their skin
a little or they make their hair look a
little more slicked back or something
they physically made themselves resemble
Italian people more is that not okay the
left objects the left's as well black
people have been oppressed in America
and white people have not been oppressed
so it's universally always terrible and
you never acceptable to wear black face
always offensive but if a black person
wears white face or you know dresses up
like an Italian for a Jersey Shore party
or something that is okay that's
perfectly fine first of all everybody
suffers everybody has experienced some
pain and suffering in their life every
people group suffers the largest
lynching in American history was of
Sicilian people in the late 19th century
basically they suffered that's a lot of
oppression so are you still gonna say
dressing up like the Jersey Shore is
okay
what about the Irish Irish faced plenty
of oppression in America I mean there
were signs on doors that said I wish
need not apply for work so when we go
out on st. Patty's Day and wear green
suits and go drinking and speaking fake
Irish brogues is that are we allowed to
do that the Irish have been oppressed
everybody suffers certainly but let's
even indulge the premises let's say that
okay you can't it's okay for some people
to do it but not okay for others it's
okay for in the victim hierarchy for the
more oppressed class of people to dress
up like the less oppressed class of
people or the oppressor class of people
but it's not okay vice-versa
and what about drag what about drag what
about transvestitism because we're told
by the left that men oppress women and
have always oppressed women and only now
thanks to feminism do they not oppress
women I
some issue with that history but let's
even indulge the premise then how on
earth are you gonna let men dress up
like women put in long hair paint their
nails put makeup on wear a dress and
high heels that's just the blackface of
sex and it's it's almost a direct
analogy according to the left's premises
because you have the the oppressor group
the men dressing up like the oppressed
group the women so is it not okay to
wear drag why are men allowed to dress
up like women not only are they laughs
allowed today actually by the way the
left is encouraging that to happen
they're celebrating that their only hope
for AIDS to celebrate men dressing up
like women and none of us really has a
problem with that I mean I was just in
New York which you know I was actually
down in Greenwich Village for a little
bit of it and in and around the village
there's a drag bar like every three
three blocks walked by Stonewall in the
very famous gay bar in New York plenty
of people dressing up plenty crazy waste
no one had a problem with it what it all
comes down to is context nobody knows
the history of blackface anymore it's
actually a very interesting history
blackface comes from the old minstrel
shows so this was a form of vaudevillian
entertainment in the US and arguably
it's it's certainly the first uniquely
American form of theater it's arguably
the only uniquely American form of
theater and in the minstrel show broadly
you have white people dressing up like
black people and specifically stock
characters of black people so one one
criticism of minstrel shows is they
portray black people as stupid and this
is actually different from what Jimmy
Kimmel did when Jimmy Kimmel dressed up
like Karl Malone even though they might
have said the same things and look the
same way Jimmy Kimmel was was making fun
of a single person he was calling one
single person an idiot whereas in the
minstrel shows you're talking about
whole stock stereotypes of people so
it's not just one individual but it's
black people generally are slaves
generally that's one difference but
what's funny is that the minstrel shows
aren't only attacked by people who
support racial equality for instance
they weren't even just attacked
by integrationist for instance at the
time they were attacked by everybody and
for opposite reasons so it's it's funny
because they were very very popular in
the 19th century in the very early part
of the 20th century but they still
managed to offend everybody so
integrationists objected to minstrel
shows because they portrayed black
people is dumb and and is happy slaves
so it almost sort of defending the
institution of slavery because it
falsely portrayed the slaves as really
happy and content with the whole thing
but the segregationists opposed minstrel
shows and objected to them because they
portrayed the black characters as
sympathetic and they humanize the black
characters and they exposed white
audience the white audiences rather to
some actual black songs so some of the
songs that were sung were just written
by white people and they were sort of
caricatures of black spirituals some of
them were actual black songs though and
black spirituals that were then exposing
white audiences to some small aspects of
black culture I say small aspects
because you'd only get that for like one
or two acts of the show the rest of it
there was a sort of vaudevillian format
our society does not object to
non-italians dressing up like Mike the
situation right our society does not
object to men dressing up like women far
from it we actually encourage it our
society does not really even object to
white people darkening their skin for
costumes we know they don't because all
those other people have their careers
Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Billy Crystal
all of them what it all does come down
to is context Justin Trudeau's Arabian
costume is not funny because he was
mocking Arab people and saying that he's
so much better than Arab people and Arab
people are dumb and terrible and
racially inferior that that's not what
he was doing I don't think the reason
his Arab costume is funny is because
it's so incongruous that it's ridiculous
you have Justin Trudeau who is the
whitest Canadian aspersion that has ever
walked the earth
and you have him dressing up as an
Arabian Prince that's funny
humor very often comes from inking
and subverting expectations Trudeau
apparently darkened his skin on another
occasion to look like Harry Belafonte
this is very funny because Harry
Belafonte is a cool
suave Jamaican American singer who was
very popular for a long time and Justin
Trudeau is a square stiff white is the
newly driven snow Canadian for the
Millennials and Gen Z in the audience
who might not recognize Harry Belafonte
Harry Belafonte is the guy who sang
daylight come in me want to go home this
is a clip of Harry Belafonte take a
listen me said Dave you know that song
you've all heard that song justin
trudeau singing that song is even more
ridiculous than me singing that song
because justin trudeau is whiter and
more Canadian than I am it's funny it's
funny to compare Justin Trudeau to Harry
Belafonte they're very different people
I don't think he was singing that song
to disparage all black people are all
Jamaican people he was wearing it
because it's funny because the
comparison is funny so the question is
how should conservatives react we'll get
to that in one second because I have a
different answer than a lot of other
conservatives have but first I've got to
thank our friends over at Vistaprint
vistaprint is so great I've used them
for so many years long before the Daily
wire even existed it's important to keep
a business card on you I don't do that a
lot and then I look like an immature
schmuck you need it you need a business
cards your next big opportunity could be
coming around the corner and you need to
be able to give out your information
vistaprint will help you own the now
with free shipping on any business card
in any quantity they're the best they're
the kings of this they are the absolute
top of the heap that's why I've always
used them you can choose whatever style
whatever finish whatever shape whatever
paper you like and you can get free
shipping I just got some business cards
made I actually didn't even get business
cards made I got calling cards made
because I think calling cards look a
little cooler than business cards but
you know decide for yourself nice linen
paper or just really
beautiful court a very simple takes two
seconds to do it you choose everything
you can choose the fonts that designs
the colors the images it helps you
create something as unique and
compelling as your business are you
ready to get started on your business
card you should be it's very easy these
guys the best it don't look this is
something you don't need to think about
too hard go out there plug in your
information plug in your logo you get
hundreds of fresh designs tailored to
your type of company or you can upload
your own original layout you pick
everything you can even upgrade it to a
unique touch likes a rounded corners or
other paper paper qualities order and
receive your cards with free economy
shipping you can feel good knowing that
vistaprint uses only carefully selected
inks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back they'll
make it right this different wants you
to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why listeners will
get free shipping on all business cards
any style any quantity go to
vistaprint.com and enter promo code
Knolls - for free shipping on all
business cards any style any quantity
Knowles - I enter like maybe Beyonce has
them as a sponsor - limited time off or
owned than now at vistaprint.com promo
code Knowles - that's the number - kano
wles number - promo code knowles
followed by the number - you support our
show when you support our sponsors thank
you so what do we do about Trudeau some
say it's none of our business you know
it's a foreign country it's Canada you
know we don't need to get in their
affairs but that's the point it's Canada
it's like America's hat Washington's
greatest mistake so the best-case
scenario here is to get the lift left to
admit in writing and on camera that
their attacks on people like Meghan
Kelly are completely disingenuous and
that life and art are complicated that's
what we should be aiming for I don't
care if Justin Trudeau resigns I get a
kick out of him and he's kind of funny
to read about in the news that's the
best-case scenario okay and we should be
perfectly honest about that if they
don't do that
then we need to make Trudeau resign some
conservatives have trouble holding these
two ideas in their head at the same time
the best solution is for the left to
admit that they were wrong that they're
vindictive that they're shallow that
they're small people and that they're
not going to do it again get them on
record doing them that is the best
scenario if they won't do that we have
to make him resign because what that
would mean is even though Trudeau did
not
commit some impeachable offense the left
won't respond to reason and mercy and
grace and so then you got to make them
feel the pain in the consequence of
their actions there is news by the way
from the left that is even more
ridiculous than Trudeau wearing
blackface this we have to get to before
the mailbag it's a new initiative from
NBC News it's called climate confessions
climate confessions they've established
a confessional here is the headline
climate confessions even those who care
deeply about the planets future can slip
up now and then tell us where do you
fall short in preventing climate change
do you blast the AC throw out half your
lunch grill a steak every week share
your anonymous confession with NBC News
it's even an anonymous confession they
don't have the little boots but they do
it all online here are some examples an
energy confession I sleep with the air
conditioner on year-round and justify it
to myself by recycling here's a meat
confession I just can't get behind the
impossible burger I'm sorry here's a
paper confession my work lunches are the
worst so much disposable everything so
those are real confessions from the
website you can read them the way you do
is you go and you pick a category then
you write down your confession I put out
an energy confession I said I
occasionally read NBC and watch NBC News
that's my confession and I'm really
sorry that I do that this obviously is
going to create some sectarian strife
among Protestant environmentalists who
just want to confess their sins to the
mother earth directly but listen for me
being a little more in the Catholic side
of the issue here I like that NBC is at
least creating this secular sacrament we
were just talking yesterday about this
about how climate change is the left
religion it's not about science it's
about religion specifically it's about
false religion and so look we don't need
to get into that again it's very clear
the left ditched real religion and they
had to adopt these false religions
because everybody's got to serve
somebody I'm glad to be able to tell you
I was completely right totally called it
I've been saying it for years and now
NBC proves that that is true I mean
they're even creating these sacraments
now mint perfectly mimicking the
Catholic sacraments the traditional
sacraments of our culture but there's
another aspect here which we haven't
touched on too much which is
environmentalism also fulfills the
political usefulness of
religion not just the religious longings
themselves man as a religious being we
are born naturally with a longing for
God it also fulfills the political
usefulness so conservatives embrace the
religious right at least 3040 years ago
and that has been very useful to us
politically it gives conservatives the
moral high ground if only because the
left has ceded the moral high ground and
they've embraced and and flaunted all
sorts of inversions and perversions of
moral norms with the left though is
doing now with the increasingly
religious tenor of environmentalism is
they're trying to counter that they
realize that's useful politically and
they want it themselves the clearest
example of that is Pete Buddha jej Pete
Budaj edges just to compare him talking
about climate change to abortion tells
you all you need to know about this
we'll get to it in one second and then
we'll get to the mailbag but first I got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
you know what you get ten bucks a month
hundred dollars for an annual membership
you get everything and you get the left
is tears tumblr and that's the most
important thing of all head on over to
daily wire.com if people don't make all
their climate change confessions and the
world heats up and the ice caps melt
you're gonna drown more likely the ice
caps aren't gonna melt but you're still
going to drown because the leftist tears
are gonna flow everywhere go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
Pete Buddha judge my least favorite
candidate running in the Democratic
field the biggest jerk out of all of
them has come out he's been doing this
now for weeks and weeks taking what NBC
News is showing us taking the religious
there were the political usefulness of
religion and most decisively you
describing this in terms of climate
change in environmentalism here's Pete
Buddha Jay's using the word sin using
the concept of sin to describe climate
change if you believe that God is
watching as poison is being belched into
the air of creation and people are being
harmed by it countries are at risk of
vanishing in low-lying areas we suppose
God thinks of that I bet he thinks it's
messed up at least one way of talking
about this is that it's a kind of sin
the point I'm thinking maybe just in my
own faith tradition but what kind of sin
is it to blame God for something you did
and something you can do something about
while other people are getting hurt the
way I see it I don't imagine that God's
gonna let us off the hook for abusing
future generations anymore that then you
would be off the hook for harming
somebody right next to you and with
climate change we're doing both the key
word there is imagine because you notice
people who judge can't really do a great
job quoting scripture or the tradition
of the church because what he is
expounding on is heresy what he is
selling is heresy it's it's a religion
that he's saying is Christianity but it
is not Christianity and so he always
just talks about what he imagines you
know forget that it's very clear from
the book of Genesis man has dominion
over the land in the sea and the beasts
and the birds now forget about that in
in Buddha judges made up version
fictional heretical Christianity we are
only here to serve the natural
environment but but at least you know
hypocrisy is the tribute vice based to
virtue he's at least pretending that
he's talking about Christianity now
listen to the religious terms in which
people judge discusses abortion now
right now
they hold everybody in line with this
one kind of piece of doctrine about
abortion right which is obviously a
tough issue for a lot of people to think
through morally then again you know
there's a lot of parts of the Bible to
talk about how life begins with breath
and so even that is something that we
can interpret differently and I'm
pro-choice pickup me too
but I think no matter where you think
about the kind of cosmic question of how
life begins most Americans can get on
the board with the idea of alright I
might draw the line here you might draw
the line there but the most important
thing is the person who should be
drawing the line is the woman making the
decision absolutely
all heretical nonsense I mean all just
absolutely demonic and a hellish
heretical nonsense
to defend the slaughter of babies we
don't have time to get into it now
father Frank Pavone the head of priests
for life has a wonderful article
describing all of the scriptural
references where we can see that God
knows us from the very beginning when he
formed us and our mothers wombs and you
see this throughout the Bible and and
what people judges is talking about is
really disgusting stuff but there's a
story that just came out of South Bend
an abortion clinic that the Buddha judge
has supported in the past in South Bend
an abortionist from there was found to
have 2,200 more than 2,200 baby body
parts found in his home Buddha judge was
finally asked about this here's his
answer like everyone I find that news
out of Illinois extremely disturbing and
I think it's important that that be
fully investigated I also hope that it
doesn't get caught up in politics at a
time when there's no question that what
happened is disturbing it's unacceptable
he doesn't want it to get caught up in
politics this is Pete Buddha judge who
is specifically making this a political
issue is running in part on this issue
abortion of course is a political issue
now and it has been for at least 50
years this guy's so in support of
abortion he's trying to twist the Bible
for his sick crusade to kill babies
he is so the worst Buddha judge is so
the worst candidate anyway why is it
disturbing cuz as we say he said this
story is disturbing the story that the
abortionist has 2200 baby body parts in
his home why is that disturbing
Pipo to judge is saying is it's not
disturbing to murder little babies and
chop them up but it is disturbing to
have the body parts to when somebody is
murdered the disturbing thing about that
is not how the family handles the
funeral they picked this casket or that
casket they serve chicken or beef at the
funeral what's disturbing is the murder
there is no way to get around this it
says oh yes we need to defend it is good
it is moral it is Christian and Biblical
to chop up little babies rip them into
different different parts pull them limb
from limb discard them like they're
nothing but meat that's good and
wonderful and virtuous and true and
Biblical but then having the body parts
is not that's bad that's disturbing it's
not disturbing totally backwards
that's the bizarre moral code the
bizarre logical consequence of the
immoral code of these false leftist
religions including environmentalism
which would have us all you hear about
from environmentalism is have fewer
babies live less thrive less be less
productive in some cases kill your
babies go that would be good for the
environment sacrifice your babies on the
altar of the climate no different than
any other pagan religion we've got a lot
more to get to but we got to get to the
mailbag so let's just fly right through
it today and we'll get to some more
stories next week from Dave dear st.
Michael of the Blessed Co FFA do you
have any suggestions about how to
improve on speaking more eloquently in
day-to-day life yes make a point of not
saying uh or um or like and to a lesser
degree but also importantly you know
just take those out of your speech it's
very difficult I mess up on this
sometimes too I use those words on
occasion but some people use those words
a lot and you'll notice that you use it
a lot more than you think you do don't
do that one of the advantages is that
you don't sound like a valley girl from
the 80s the other advantage is it will
cause you to stop you will stop speaking
for a second and that will allow you to
which means that the things that you are
saying are going to be more eloquent and
better thought out I would recommend
slowing down I would recommend speaking
on your breath
one way that Millennials and Gen Z gens
Alissa I notice Millennials do this
though is they'll speak in vocal fry'
but vocal fry' is like when you talk
like this you know so there's no real
air or supporting it but it's just kind
of in the back of the throat and it
sounds really unpleasant and ugly
speak on your breath it will give off a
sense of confidence it will make you
feel more confident about your ideas and
it will be more persuasive those are
just a few things you can do also read
poetry read good language read good
books and memorize poetry memorize as
poetry is easy because you can memorize
a poem in an hour or to memorize verses
from the Bible memorized Shakespeare
memorize good quotes that you like we
have gotten much worse about our
memories because we have electronics in
front of us all the time so we don't
recall anything but so much of speaking
publicly is about recalling quotes and
thoughts and ideas and who said it in
the citations so just work on building
up your memory and when you do memorize
things do it with your mouth do it on
your voice don't just do it in your head
big exaggerated movements from your
mouth and from your vocal cords this
will make it much easier to memorize
things and it will make you a better
speaker from Kyle Michael loved the show
it's art in one of its purest forms
thank you very much with Democrats
racing to see who you can who can have
the most radical policy by 2020 what
hope do you have for true bipartisanship
or a renewal of agreement on common
values between Republicans and Democrats
when some of the most fundamental
disagreements we have at this point seem
irreconcilable
I think bipartisanship is nonsense I
mean it's a contradiction in a term
partisanship means there is a
disagreement there is a separation there
is division so bipartisanship is a
contradiction in itself and I don't even
think we necessarily want that I don't
want a big a liberal consensus in this
country I like that I get to stay my
point of view and other people get to
state they're incorrect points of view
and then the I can persuade people to
agree with what I think to put it
bluntly so that's fine I like a good
rigorous debate I don't like the censor
I don't like the constant character
attacks I don't like dredging up old
tweets Twitter is a little bit of the
problem though I was on a fox news show
when I was in New York a couple days ago
and it was martha maccallum show and I
was on with Juan Williams Juan and I
disagree on an whole number of things
I'm sure we could easily go back and
snipe at each other on Twitter all day
long but when you're in the room looking
at somebody face to face you take them
more seriously you treat them more
respectfully that would be good I think
that we could do with a whole lot more
respect and reverence in this country
but that's going to come from a place of
humility and personal interaction
unfortunately we're losing humility
because we now have a whole month that
celebrates pride which is the opposite
of humility and we have much less
personal interaction because more and
more and more we're just behind our
screens and we're all keyboard warriors
with the courage of people who never
have to face consequences for what they
say so in short I don't think that the
future of good civil discourse is
looking very bright and the only way
that we can try to create that culture
now with all of the technological and
social challenges is to embody it and
have a little reverence and have a
little humility ourselves from Brandon
dear Michael if the 2020 candidates have
their way and make College free do you
think we will see a dramatic drop-off in
the quality of education yes of course
we already have as as the federal
government has come in and subsidized
loans and underwritten college loans and
the quality of the education has
declined dramatically as more and more
people have gone to college the quality
of the education has declined
dramatically in the 1940s that 5% of
Americans had a Bachelor degree today
60% of high school graduates are going
to go to college they may drop out but
they're going to go we have too many
people going to college and we have too
much of a one-size-fits-all solution
some people shouldn't go to get a
liberal education some people should go
and get a trade education and by trade
education by the way I mean study
business or study accounting or study
pre-law or study because even even law
school is really a trade education
they're usually you need a liberal
education before that or you study some
aspect of the medical field or you know
learn how to buff hardwood floors or
become an electrician or become a
plumber you don't need or go to seminary
I mean that's it that's a different sort
of education and involves a liberal
education and it involves something else
education should be tailored to the
individuals
and we're losing that and I think that's
just a function of a democratic society
which wants to level down and make
everybody exactly equal so that's a
process that's already been happening
and once you make college into just 13th
grade you're gonna see the colleges are
you're going to see happening at the
colleges what was already happening in
public school education from
kindergarten through 12 and that's part
of a long process that's been going on
it'll probably continue to happen
whether or not Liz Warren gets her free
college for everybody plan it's a it's a
much bigger problem than this election
from Danielle hi Michael I listened to
your show and I appreciate your
perspective into all aspects of life my
boyfriend and I have been together for
almost four years I'm 32 and he's 47
recently the question of are we ready to
get married
came up again the I'm not sure we're
ready answer that I eventually received
from him is obviously not what I wanted
to hear however this day and age seems
to complicate feelings and futures and
now so many people aren't sure of
anything
what sort of insight do you have on this
given that you and your wife had a
longer winding courtship and that dating
and marrying for Millennials is sort of
a train wreck this is sort of a trailer
as an understatement
this is a heartbreaking question to have
floating around in my mind but how do I
wait but but do I wait and work on the
relationship or call it quits tell him
to piss or get off the pot simple as
that it is true I dated sweet little
ELISA for so long in part cuz we dated
when we were little kids dated one you
know I we met when we were 9 or 10 and
were dating when we were 16 and we split
for college then got back together and
in this very millennial way waited a
long time and moved all around the
country and those sort of things I wish
I'd got married sooner it would have
been better to do that and I sort of
wish she had told me what I just told
you my grandmother and grandfather dated
for a while
and eventually she gave him that
ultimatum as well piss or get off the
pot that's what you should tell him to
do especially because I mean you're
younger than he is it seems you're 32
and he's 47 but he's 47 he's no young
boy I'd cut him off
I'd take the lice estrada strategy I
would make him make a decision and make
him act like a man he's certainly old
enough to be one and there's no two ways
about that don't wait around for even
two seconds make him make a decision
you can move on with your life if he
doesn't want to do it or go get married
because sometimes men just need a little
push for Melanie hello Michael I'd love
to know your opinions on the 26th
president of the US of A Teddy Roosevelt
he was a fascinating and inspirational
man in his personal life but I've heard
conflicting views on his politics as
president and whether they helped the
u.s. in the long run or not what do you
think Thanks I love Teddy Roosevelt some
libertarians don't like him because he'd
like to nail parks too much and called
himself progressive even though then
that term had it certainly a different
connotation than it does now I think
he's great
I think he's basically America he's loud
he's boisterous
the guy got shot one time finished
giving a speech and then only then went
to a hospital you know the guy gets
attacked and he attacks the people right
back he goes over to Africa and bags
hundreds of large game he's just
terrific he's just a great a great
historical figure John Milius one of the
great filmmakers who's still living
today has a good movie on Teddy
Roosevelt the wind and the lion go check
it out there's a great speech by the
character playing Teddy Roosevelt of how
the grizzly bear is America and this is
I think he very much embodies that
spirit whether or not his policies in
the early 20th century
really matter or don't really matter
whatever look politics is contextual and
politics is circumstantial and it
changes over time so historical views of
the president's change but as an
American character I think he's just
absolutely terrific final question from
Samuel what are your favorite last words
either historical or fictional it is
said that Pope Benedict the 15th his
last words on his deathbed were la
comedia if you need them which is
quoting it's quite an opera Pagliacci or
something which is the comedy is
finished and I love these last words
because they're funny there there's some
wit there the idea that obviously hid
the comedy of his life is coming to an
end but also that it's a comedy life
isn't just a farce he's not saying it's
a comedy like it's an absurd joke but
big cosmic joke it's a comedy in that it
has a happy ending we have a happy
ending our life has a happy ending this
world has a happy ending this is what
the Divine Comedy is all about and I
think those are the perfect last words
and if I know that my end is coming I
hope I repeat them when when my time
comes
all right that's our show our time is up
here I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see how Monday
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is nick Chien the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show should we go to
war with Iran should we care about
Justin Trudeau wearing blackface
should we go to war with Canada how to
make for an interesting afternoon we'll
talk about that and also murder most
Democrat a shocking story out of
California on the Andrew Klay
[Music]